[Music]
war is a universal language
I know renegade so - mercy never
occurred to me that one might come from
above there's a moment in the movie
where Carol actually realizes she
doesn't even really know who she is has
there ever been a moment in your life
where you feel like you haven't really
realized who you were of course that's
just part of that's part of life I mean
I go through that all the time but in
particular I always go through it after
movies over yeah it was an exciting time
yeah because I end up spending probably
like I mean on the high end maybe at 16
hours a day as somebody else so the only
time I have as myself is when I'm asleep
and dreaming when I'm on a movie so then
when the movies over you have this
period of time you kind of get to unlock
things and go okay I've been this other
person what things from this character
do I want to keep what do I want to let
go of like what do I like what do I want
to eat who do I want to be what time do
I wake up like yeah you're living under
a schedule kind of serving a character
then you get a chance to to rethink who
you are how your day goes yeah totally
one of my favorite parts this movie some
in 90s baby is the blockbuster cam you
know I feel like blockbuster was such a
part of like growing up going every
Friday night with my family renting the
same movie over and over again
did you ever have like a go-to movie
rental at Blockbuster yeah I mean my my
memories are so young at Blockbuster
that the the VHS DVD the VHS that I wore
out at Blockbuster was the Shelley
Duvall the fairytale theater I don't
know if you grew up watching that and
those show that she did of fairytales
but me and my sister wore out the VHS it
didn't work anymore cuz we had rented it
so that's so funny I would always forget
to rewind them so I always felt bad for
the person that got the movie after me
because I'd like to sit there and they'd
be like oh no actually rewind the whole
movie all over again
we'll see that's a yes or no question
yes there's a point in this movie where
Carol kind of she has this moment where
she realizes she doesn't know who she is
was there ever a moment in your life
where you didn't know who you were
pretty sure there was well they're all
that was a long period in my life where
I lived an alternate reality of who I
was or what I wanted to be or I didn't
like who I was so I just eliminated that
from my physical being and just you know
I used a lot of substances and became
something else but Carol Carol Carol
doesn't know who she is but what's great
about Carol is she's she's a strong
individual that has done all these
things and when she comes back to this
particular place what she does discover
about herself is that she had a life
worth living right that she was a strong
person that she did accomplish things
that she was this force of nature of her
home so that when all these other people
are trying to reinforce her with you are
nothing without us she finally realizes
well I was something before I met you so
I can still be that strong thing I was
without you which made our even stronger
right it's kind of great it's like you
and Carol have a lot in common
Yeah right um one of my favorite parts
of this movie because I'm a 90s baby
it's the blockbuster cameo and I feel
like every Friday night me and my family
would go to Blockbuster and rent the
same movie every time did you ever have
like a go to movie rental blockbuster go
to movie about buster um
[Music]
probably the first die hard cuz I like
that movie so much but I also bought I
would I would rent cheap obscure karate
movies then nobody had cuz you know
they'll run out of movies so I had this
whole other section of blockbuster that
I went to that nobody went to so I was
always good that's so funny
mine was Nick Fury agents of shield
[Laughter]
really okay do you think they'd ever
remake that movie no do they need to
yeah I think you see on your lip the
guys II would you like to know what you
really are
I think I had a life here
what are you telling me well this movie
is obviously so important to women
around the world but I'm curious to know
who is the most important woman Manish
in your life been to write for men to
see boys to see women in this position
is as important in a way sorry
no I'm hide your assignments it's
because it's done in such a subtle
powerful way that little boys seeing a
woman in that position and women acting
like that I think it's just as important
that they learn that this is right
as as it is to inspire the young women
who are gonna see it my favorite part of
this movie is the blockbuster cameo cuz
when I was little I'd always go to
Blockbuster with my family it was such a
part of like you know our family
tradition
did you guys have like a go to movie
rental Blockbuster oh I didn't I had a
local one I had a little tiny kind of
store in in Blackheath Village and I I
mean I'm a complete film geek so I think
I saw almost every film in that video
store yeah
did you rewind them after returning them
I did actually yeah I missed that whole
routine date yeah dude yeah I do I miss
it a lot because also when you you'd
rent one on a Friday night or your
parents would I mean me my sister would
watch it go back it's got to get back to
us watch it again watch our favorite bit
yeah if you go a little bit late and all
the new releases have gone you've just
got to pick something else and you can
be surprised in a one that's right
and you end up in the older section yeah
yeah yeah I love that
anyway did you ever go to movie rental
clueless I definitely rented more than
once
yeah love that film that was 90 that's
funny as if there's a moment in this
movie where Carol kind of realizes that
she doesn't really know who she is
hmm did you guys ever have a moment like
that in life Bailey
yeah that's life right yeah that's why
there's a message in this film I think
that has it's it's what they're very
good at doing in this universe they're
very good at finding themes that have
some kind of a relationship with us as
viewers and and they sort of tap into
humanity I suppose but right I think
that's something that we all struggle
with and and life is about rediscovering
who you are but constantly asking the
question yeah yeah and behaving in a way
that anything is that me that mean I
couldn't it's not new in the older you
get that shifts and changes I keep
having these memories
Bessie flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
one of my favorite parts of this movie
it was the blockbuster cameo because I
was born in the 90s and I'm curious to
know did you have like a go-to movie
rental at Blockbuster ooh oh my gosh
I've been so turned by modern-day
technology that I'm like blockbusters
what does that you know I can't remember
probably cuz I maybe didn't bring them
back in time I was telling everyone else
that I'd always get in trouble because I
would never like rewind the movie so
what we got it was that um gosh I
actually can't think you know what I was
a really big animations fan I loved a
big Disney fan so I loved lady in the
[ __ ] like that was my go-to I still
have it on VHS actually and that
ghostbusters Goonies these will come
rushing back now although those aren't
90s but that's what I was watching in
the 90s I'm an 80s baby I'm not gonna
fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
my favorite part of this movie is the
blockbuster cameo because I feel like
blockbuster was such a tradition in my
household like every Friday I'd go and
I'd rent the same movie so I'm wondering
did you guys have any go to movie
rentals at Blockbuster I actually worked
in a blockbuster in 1995 so it is also
personal to me but in terms of go-to
rentals I mean yeah they were there was
so many but yeah pulp fiction was it was
in constant rotation wait Ryan that's
insane that's like so full circle that
you worked at a blockbuster in 1995 for
for me um I all I can remember is that I
had to get cut off from renting
Ghostbusters 2 because I don't know why
2 but for some reason I just wanted to
watch Ghostbusters 2 over and over and
over again and at one point my
babysitter was like we're not doing that
we're not watching them anymore there's
a moment in this movie where Carol kind
of doesn't realize is that she doesn't
really know who she is was there ever a
moment in your life where you kind of
didn't realize who you were you know one
day I think I'll figure it out but not
quite there yet that's but it's the
journey
yes the journey were on yeah and I don't
think even though Carol figures out a
key element of her her past in this
movie I think she'll always be learning
about who she is as the movie goes on
and as is the her life goes on yeah we
are all works in progress
you